we've got kelsey on the line kelsey how
can we help you today
hey guys good afternoon hey thanks for
hanging on for so long kelsey how can we
help today
no worries um so i um my husband and i
um we are in baby step number two
um we have four kiddos going on number
five
um and we are trying to
get our kids on board with our what
we're doing at home
and we're really struggling with our
oldest
um it's got to apologize to it
oh it's okay hard to get to this one um
so we actually got full custody of our
oldest
in um february and
he went through a really emotionally
traumatic experiment
with his uh biological mother in august
and we he's been doing therapy and
and really doing as much work as an
eight-year-old can do on his end
um and his daughter one we're at the
point where we're wondering how we can
kind of help him along
with being with his mom he is used to
um getting gifts and going on shopping
sprees and that kind of thing
from his grandpa they all lived together
anytime his mom would come up short his
grandpa would kind of take him to go
and and spend all kinds of money and
just kind of cover up what happened
and we're trying to um help him
understand that
and we love him and care for him even if
we don't go
to the store and we get a toy every day
or even if we don't go to the gas
station get
you know a snack or go out to eat and
he's kind of he associates fine things
with love i was wondering if you had any
advice for my husband and i on
how we can kind of help him know hey we
love you a ton
but this is a family goal that we have
we have so many other kids
you know we want to make sure that
you're feeling loved
but in a way that's that's also going to
help our family progress
at the same time yeah i love that
question and thank you so much for your
heart and trust
um with that question how old is he
uh he's eight oh beautiful okay so
here's a couple of things you can do
with an eight-year-old um
and any kid that suffered a traumatic
injury a traumatic relationship
break um good for you for getting him
professional help good for you for
going through the gnarly messy
gritty transition to get full custody i
know that's not fun or pleasurable for
anybody
he's going to have some healing to do
some things you can do with an
eight-year-old
involve asking him to take ownership and
leadership of
helping with the younger kids he's going
to have to be built up from the inside
out i'll put it that way
right now he's got a lot of external
plugs
to internal holes and those things leak
they don't work
and so you can't plug up hurt or missed
relationships or
gap in connection with toys and food and
things
but for the eight-year-old mind it it
band-aids over to the next day or the
next day the next day
so you're in for a long transition but
it's going to be quicker than you think
what he will need more than anything
else is your direct attention
your love and direct connection and
those sound dramatic and hard
with four and five on the way for you
that's going to be hard your husband's
gonna have to step in that gap in a
major way
but these are little things like hey
will you grab one of the other kids and
let's go outside and play soccer this
afternoon
and he's gonna say i wanna think and say
i know i got you but i want you to come
out and play soccer with me
or can you help take these other two
kids would you go read to them
would you go show them what a big
brother does when right and so what what
you want to do is you're going to build
him you're going to heal him from the
inside out
and that's through ownership teaching
him leadership and here's going to be
the hard part
you're going to have to teach him
boundaries kids crave
desperately crave boundaries and he's
never had them
or the ones he had were fake and they
fell over somebody else propped them up
and there is going to be a transition
time it's going to be painful it's going
to be
annoying you're going to think are we
doing the right thing the answer is yes
but you're going to have to put up some
firm boundaries if you
help with x y and z then you can earn
your way to
some own money of your own that you can
buy your own toys with
and then he's going to smash up against
those things to see if they hold
he's going to crash against your
boundaries sincere are they strong do
they really love me and care about me
and that's a process he's going to have
to learn and it's going to take that's
going to take a couple years
so you just got to buckle up with that
one but i would start with ownership
leadership asking him to take an active
participant
older brother leadership role in the
house and then
catch him being good yeah praise him
when he does right don't just look for
the things
oh we don't talk like that in the house
we don't find him when he when he
acknowledges that one little sibling he
said can i get some water and he grabs a
cup and does it
pull him aside and look in the eye and
say hey thank you for doing that that's
right
thank you for being a leader in this
house and he will heal from the inside
out it's not going to be easy it's not
going to be fun
but man you will you will you will help
that boy grow
from the inside out and you're talking
about a transition changed legacy for
that young man that's amazing and john
you know you start to hear this and
um obviously i hear eight-year-old but i
you you can easily start to know adults
oh yeah who have grown accustomed to
love
being shown by the purchasing of
something that's right
right and it is is this process of
trying to to gain love by buying and
what you'll find is some people have
such a hole inside of them right
that they're in enough gifts or time
that you can deposit
in there that's ever going to make a
difference that's right i often and same
with work
right like i just need to make more
money i need to be at a different
company a bigger company
and i always tell folks man the worst
part about getting a new job the worst
part about getting a new car
the worst part about getting a new
husband or wife is that you go with you
hmm you're the one that gets behind that
wheel and two weeks later you're gonna
realize
that i didn't work i need a faster car a
bigger car right you go with
you and so what you can do with an
eight-year-old is remind him no we're
with you
yeah you're a person of value you're
more important than a toy
you're more important than another sugar
drink or whatever it is
you've got value because we love you you
got value just because you're in our
home hey
real quick for parents that are dealing
with split
homes um but this little boy situation
let's say he's going there every other
week
right and so the the work you do with
him
as it's moving forward then he goes back
right
to to disneyland or or toyland
right and then coming back so you know
you would think for kelsey and her
husband
they're going to have to have the long
haul game it's a long day you're playing
a long game and one day that 22 year
old's gonna look back and say i was
loved
yes i was loved that's good i got i got
high one place
i was whole in another place it's a long
game but
but you're doing wholly right work when
you do that and kelsey make sure you and
your husband are staying connected
that's right you guys are able to
verbalize your irritations your
frustrations as well as the celebrations
do this stuff together we love you
kelsey yes this is the dave ramsey show